thorsten frei ist bei uns
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der union herr frei
wenn wir jetzt bei diesem impfen bleiben
und das sollten wir ruhig mal einen
moment denn es ist ja das wichtigste was
wir jetzt eigentlich organisieren wollen
der spiegel schreibt wir priorisieren
uns zu tode
die hausärzte könnten eigentlich und
wollen eigentlich weil sie die patienten
übrigens auch gut kennen jetzt ist das
wieder verschoben
verstehen sie manchmal noch was wir
betreiben haben sie noch erklärungen
dafür
das grundproblem bleibt hier hat das wir
zurzeit eine mangelsituation beim
impfstoff haben und so lange wir das
haben ist es sicherlich richtig zu
priorisieren zu entscheiden in welcher
reihenfolge das passiert und da haben
wir durchaus erfolge in deutschland wir
haben jetzt etwa zwei drittel der
bewohner von alten und pflegeheimen
geimpft wir haben gesehen dass die zahl
der toten deutlich zurückgegangen ist
die intensivstationen sind etwa halb so
stark ausgelastet wie das noch mitte
januar der fall war
insofern bei allen schwierigkeiten gibt
es fortschritte
stimmt es liegt auf der einen seite aber
impfstoff immer noch herum auf der
anderen seite fragt man sich natürlich
auch ob wir mit diesem hausärzte sollen
warten tatsächlich lieber wollen dass
gar niemand geimpft wird anstatt die
falschen zu impfen also verzweifeln sie
da manchmal nicht wer das darf
jedenfalls nicht passieren denn jeder
geimpfte ist ein guter der hilft uns bei
der bekämpfung der pandemie und bei der
rückkehr in die normalität und deswegen
darf man es glaube ich sobald diese
mangelsituation sich anfängt aufzulösen
und wahrscheinlich sind wir schon in
dieser phase drin nicht zu sehr auf
diese priorisierungen schauen sondern
das entscheidende ist es dass kein
impfstoff übrig bleibt das alles
verimpft wird und dass wir da eben auch
schauen dass wir das so schnell wie
möglich erreicht machen
georg mascolo ist bei uns journalist
geschätzt als journalistin kollege
recherche verbund viele serbien marokko
die türkei es geht offensichtlich in der
entscheidenden phase in anderen ländern
wesentlich schneller als in deutschland
in welcher klasse spielen wir da gerade
als organisations weltmeister in bezug
auf das impfen ja jedenfalls nicht in
der die wir uns selber vorstellen würden
und die wir gewählt hätten wir waren
gerade bei dem thema der hausherr tzlich
muss sagen dass ich das nie verstanden
habe wieso die hausärzte nicht früher
einbezogen werden zu überprüfen wir über
80 ist über 70 ist können natürlich auch
hausärzte aber schnell und gehen der
jetzt entscheidenden frage nämlich
einzuschätzen wer ist ein hochrisiko
patient wer benötigt den impfstoff gibt
es ja niemanden der seine patienten
besser kennt als der hausarzt und ich
glaube dass wir vor allem aufpassen
müssen wenn wir nun glück haben dann
kommen wir jetzt eher in die nächste
phase und in der nächsten phase wird es
ausreichend impfstoff geben hoffentlich
jedenfalls und dann werden die hausärzte
eine ganz entscheidende rolle spielen
dann wird es darauf ankommt menschen
davon zu überzeugen sich impfen zu
lassen das heißt das passt jetzt so ein
bisschen entstanden ist glaubt auch ein
gefühl bei vielen hausärzten
wir werden da nicht frühzeitig genug
einbezogen
das ist etwas wo man sehr aufpassen muss
weil das besondere verhältnis zwischen
dem feld das vertrauensverhältnis
zwischen patientinnen und patienten und
ihren hausärzten ist etwas was wir jetzt
in der neuen phase entscheidend brauchen
noch mal zu meiner frage warum sind
andere länder so wesentlich schneller
als wir und warum bleiben wir unter
unseren möglichkeiten also habe ich all
diese länder anguckt tatsächlich nicht
nur eine antwort es gibt beispielsweise
chile ist jetzt ganz weit vorne und
chile ist beispielsweise deshalb vorne
weil sie einen chinesischen impfstoff
benutzen wer bei uns überhaupt nicht
zugelassen ist und dann gibt es eine
besonderheit bei großbritannien ob bei
der den usa die man sehen muss
die usa haben sich sehr früh entschieden
schon unter präsident trump und
präsident biden setzt das jetzt fort mit
hilfe von gesetzlichen regelungen und
exekutiven erlassen dafür zu sorgen dass
jede form von impfstoff die in den usa
hergestellt würden auch viele vor stoffe
dass die nicht exportiert werden
großbritannien ebenfalls ein großer
produzent von impfstoffen kennt keine
gesetzliche regelung aber
interessanterweise ist es so dass
jedenfalls aus großbritannien auch nicht
exportiert
schaut man sich die netto zahlen an dann
sieht man dass europa der kontinent ist
der im moment weite teile der welt
versorgt die zahlenden irgendwo zwischen
25 und 30 millionen dosen die in alle
welt ausgeliefert worden
nur ein bisschen mehr herstellen und
offensichtlich vorher auffordern soll
auch das ist sicher eine frage aber ich
will auf den punkt hinweisen dass das
selbst so weit geht dass kanada und
mexiko
die nun mit den usa auf einem kontinent
liegen und sagen wir sind europa
angrenzenden länder könnte die uns
möglicherweise helfen aus den usa mit
impfstoffen aus den usa nicht versorgt
werden sondern die exporte gehen aus der
eu dahin also ich glaube wenn diese
krise irgendwann mal vorbei sein wird
dann werden manche länder die
zuallererst und manche die auch nur an
sich gedacht haben und nicht gesehen
haben das ist ein medizinisches und ein
menschliches argument gibt anderen auch
zu helfen sich auch noch unangenehme
fragen stellen lassen
ich finde es jedenfalls besonders
enttäuschen dass ausgerechnet die usa in
dieser sache nur an ihre eigene
bevölkerung denken und wenig an den rest
der welt werden wir auf jeden fall in
der sendung noch mal london dazu hören
eine journalistin kollegin mary mcaleese
zugeschaltet begrüßen jetzt an der
stelle aber mal den ehemaligen
aussenminister der sigmar gabriel dabei
was ist so komisch an dieser krise
eigentlich sind sich doch auch in
deutschland alle einig wir wollen
möglichst schnell impfen und wir wollen
möglichst schnell testen
über das ziel gibt es also überhaupt gar
keinen streit das heißt es gibt ein
handwerkliches problem was ist dass sie
es verstanden das weiß ich nicht ich
will eine vorbemerkung machen die man
glaube ich machen muss wenn man kritisch
über die lage diskutiert ich gehöre
nicht zu denen die jetzt sagen wann wir
wissen alles besser und wir kritisieren
alle die der politische entscheidung
getroffen haben weil das natürlich der
lage ist die keiner kannte und ich finde
es fast normal dass dabei fehler gemacht
werden das finde ich nichts
erstaunliches und wir haben gerade über
zwei länder geredet die jetzt beim
impfen weit vorne liegen die haben
dramatische fehler am anfang gemacht
die usa großbritannien hat viel mehr
tote also wie er ich will das so ich
muss nur mal vorweg damit man
so also besser bis herumrennt ich glaube
es gibt einen ursachen bündel in der tat
gibt es handwerkliche probleme politik
ist zu 80 prozent handwerk 10 19%
intuition und wir haben gerade erlebt es
gibt die zentrale aufgaben kommunen
künftig oder wissen überhaupt nur wo
menschen wohnen und welches alter sie
haben das sind nämlich die meldebehörden
sie das land niedersachsen auf die idee
kommen konnte dass selbst zumal
erschließt sich mir nicht
und es gibt dinge die muss man zentral
machen zum beispiel beschaffung des
innen stoffes und das zusammen zu binden
das erfordert eine ganze menge aufwand
und ich hab mal geguckt wie ist denn das
mit den krisenstäben für sowas bildet
man dann in so einer lage einen
krisenstab
den gibt es natürlich auch jetzt der tag
glaube ich einmal in der woche
es gab mal eine andere nicht
vergleichbare krise mit dem terrorismus
in deutschland in den 70er jahren
da gab es ein krisenstab der tag drei
bis fünf mal am tag
das heißt offensichtlich haben wir
verlernt wie man mit einer krise umgeht
und wir haben auch keine strukturen auf
die wir uns verlassen können und
vielleicht ist der größte fehler den wir
gemacht haben
nach der flüchtlingskrise nicht unsere
strukturen auf die frage zu überprüfen
was machen wir eigentlich wenn dinge
passieren in großem umfang auf die wir
nicht vorbereitet sind die anders sind
als der alltag und 300 aufgaben sind
oder jahrhundert und ich glaube dass ich
glaube dass sehr viel damit zu tun hat
dass wir dieses handwerk jedenfalls
offensichtlich nicht ausreichend
beherrschen
das scheint mir eins der grundlegenden
probleme zu sagen vielleicht können wir
darüber heute auch noch ein bisschen
gründlicher reden was in diesem system
an welcher stelle revolutioniert sogar
werden müsse
herr brinkhaus hat gesagt wir brauchen
eine revolution in unserer staatlichen
verwaltung dazu kommen wir noch wir
müssen erstmal reifen müller begrüßen
der ist uns zugeschaltet spiele
natürlich bekannt aus funk und fernsehen
hat in dieser krise ll eingetauscht
gegen recklinghausen und ralf möller um
ihre betagten eltern zu bekümmern der
papi wird 92 die mama s 85
jetzt haben wir die kanzlerin zitiert
impftermin und wir müssen ein bisschen
flexibler werden deutsche flexibilität
haben sie die irgendwie schon gespielt
also nicht gespürt ich kam jetzt ist ja
im august nach deutschland und schon
damals hieß es ist kommt mir zweite
welle und alle wussten bescheid dass wir
was machen müssen die unternehmer hatten
viel geld investiert studium besitzer
restaurantbesitzer kulturstätten
wir sind heute zum größten teil pleite
aufgrund der regierung ich mache auch
keine bürger verantwortlich wie sie
vorhin schon sagten aber das ganze was
ich hier so höre klingt so als neuer als
wenn irgendwas ist meine eltern sind
ich habe mir nun mal angerufen 116 117
promotet richtig viel geld was ich dann
da erfahren habe war dass ich mich dann
wieder am 8 februar das an die impfung
müssten also damjan groß gemacht aber es
wurde wirklich nicht wichtige
informationen gab es nicht
wie kann man alte menschen 85 und 90
wie soll die selbstständig im internet
gewinnen wären impftermin organisieren
wir schauen sie mit meiner alten meine
eltern am rollers die mich wenn sie den
1200 stunden habe ich ja der rollator
und genau hier soll des orient üben
jetzt gebt dann kommt ein taxi 1 passt
ja nicht über die brauchen zwei
rollatoren so das heißt die kommen jetzt
nach unten und dann stehen wir erst mal
eine ganze weile da das wir reden jetzt
von 85 bis 92
ich verstehe gar nicht wir haben doch
gerade auch alle minister haben doch oma
opa verband alte leute und ich habe auch
viele nachbarn aber sind doch ist auch
die die die die wie soll ich sagen dass
das menschliche das geht auch da total
weg es ist doch das kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen
funktioniert diese deutsche bürokratie
in ihren augen irgendwie gar nicht oder
funktioniert so gut
nein sie ist sie ist es ist es ist so
lange es wird zur führung diskutiert es
wird wenn alle minister zusammenkam
ich hätte ja zum beispiel es gibt
internetfirmen
man kann doch innerhalb von einem monat
zum beispiel jetzt gehe ich noch im
kreishaus aus wo ich herkomm dann stelle
ich fest im kreis leben wie viel 18 bis
19 jährigen
dafür brauchte ich in stoff klar ist
doch dass wir gepennt dass wir nicht in
der bundesliga in der kreisklasse
absolut sind und wir werden auch noch
nicht im sommer durch sein
da sind die anderen schon durch dass wir
bei uns bist im september oktober
eingehen
dann gibt es jetzt schon gerne
impfstoffe wieder nicht gut ist warum
haben wir nicht was von den chinesen
warum werde ich auch mal was von den
russen im moment muss geimpft geimpft
werden und vor allem getestet gibt es
getestet werden es ist nicht mehr vor
zwölf es ist nach zwölf 70.000 menschen
sind tot
weitere werden folgen da kann ich nicht
einfach darum stehen und sagen das ist
nichts also entstand das ist eine
katastrophe politik hat absolut versagt
das muss man ganz klar sagen sie
bekommen ihr geld monatlich da draußen
sind unternehmer restaurantbesitzer
studio visite sind pleite die denkt an
selbstmord ist ein ganz ganz schlimme
sachen da draußen passiert
hier treffen sich alle drei vier
wochenenden wieder gemeinsam raus
gegangen und wir sind keinen schritt
weiter sind auch jetzt wieder alles
kleingeredet einmal nach osnabrück
talkshow wie schwer ist es irgendwie
politik da immer noch zu rechtfertigen
also die menschen hatten viel
auszuhalten sie hatten viel zu erleiden
und an den stellen an denen etwas
ermöglicht werden soll
funktioniert der staat einfach nicht
also im verbieten sind wir klasse im
ermöglichen sind wir schlecht wie
erklärt man sowas
also ich glaube noch besser sind wir
tatsächlich im schlecht machen wie mir
das hier gerade scheint also das ist
hier sehr viel gut gegangen gerade in
der ersten welle waren wir sehr schnell
und sehr viel besser als die meisten
anderen staaten und dass man jetzt hier
dieses we first so nach vorne stellt und
auch noch glorifiziert ich bin sehr froh
dass er mascolo eben noch die kurve
gekriegt hat und dass danach
eingeschränkt hat dass auch diese
staaten sich später mal fragen werden
müssen war das gut und war das richtig
klar ist wir sind hier in einer pandemie
die gilt weltweit und wenn ich alle
impfstoff haben dann ist es den staaten
auch überhaupt nichts weil die
mutationen die werden sich
weiterentwickeln und dann kommt
irgendwann der bumerang zurück also
wirklich schaffen tun wir diese krise
nur wenn wir zusehen dass möglichst
zeitgleich alle genug impfstoff haben
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt sensationell
dass wir nach einem jahr so viele
impfstoffe zur verfügung haben die
funktionieren bei uns in deutschland
wäre es niemals möglich gewesen es wäre
bei uns in deutschland niemals möglich
gewesen einen impfstoff wie astra zenica
über ein beschleunigter sogar ein
notverfahren in den markt zu bringen es
hätte sich einfach niemand impfen lassen
wir können hier nicht die länder
miteinander vergleichen und es nützt
auch nichts einfach darauf zu schimpfen
auf die politik zu schimpfen wenn wir
einfach hier mit einer mangelsituation
zu tun haben das liegt nicht in dieser
stadt ist organisiert nur wenn der
impfstoff nicht da ist dann kann auch
die politik daran tatsächlich nichts
machen und ich persönlich finde es
richtig dass wir gemeinsam mit europa
bestellt haben und dass wir auch
exportieren und nicht nur die first
sagen ich finde sie sich auch schon
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen schwierig
politikerin
und wir wollen uns sich eher nach den
ursachen fragen wir wollen uns fragen
warum wir unter unseren möglichkeiten
bleiben und sie als politikerin muss ja
auch interessieren warum aus berlin die
dinge nicht bis in den land warum die
korona helfen nicht auf die konten und
warum der impfstoff nicht in den arm
kommt woran machen sie das fest warum
ist das so warum sind wir dann
mittelklasse ja dass die versprochenen
hilfen nicht auf den konten ankommen ist
wirklich ein großes problem
ich glaube diese diskrepanz zwischen
versprechen und tatsächlich organisiert
haben ist bei uns im moment sehr groß
wir versprechen bevor wir organisiert
haben und vergessen dabei dass die
organisation eben auch ein bisschen zeit
in anspruch nimmt oder aber wir haben
eben organisiert wie bei dem impfstoff
und dann ist der impfstoff nicht
vorhanden alle sind in der warteschleife
alle wissen ist es alles organisiert und
die lieferungen kommen aber darunter
leiden denn vier jahren wäre herrn
müller noch einmal fragen ich will ihnen
jetzt auch nicht zu lange in der leitung
halten ralf müller sie pendeln zwischen
deutschland und amerika hin und her
amerika hat darüber haben wir auch schon
gesprochen in dieser ersten phase viel
viel verloren
und da standen die deutschen sehr gut da
was müssten wir jetzt lernen wenn sieben
es formulieren sollten was dürfen wir
nicht verlernen was sollten wir jetzt
als nächstes
ganz einfach ich habe letztes jahr ein
paar monaten das ist es ist sein buch
gemacht erst mal machen
das heißt also das ist genau das das
ruhrgebiet slang erstmal machen
ich sehe unsere impfung unserer
infoseite die sind leer
ich spreche mit meinem nachbarn die
warten auf ihre ihm vor es kann doch
nicht angehen dass ist alle sagen alles
ist gut gelaufen alles sehr schön das
einzige war es wirklich gut ist
es gilt gerade die korruptions
geschichten lieber alle cdu gerade
stattfinden wo sich leute 250.000
650.000 auf das alte tun das ist wie als
wenn ich vom betteln man irgendwie das
geld wegnehmen
da soll man sich schämen überall gibt es
immer aussprachen
aber nicht einmal sagt niemand dass
alles gut gelaufen ist sagte worten wir
haben ungefähr noch bis zum mai juni 80
und 90 jährige menschen die noch kein
standing haben und immer noch nicht da
sind und ihre eltern nicht sein
einem 17 uhr und am 11
und am 11 in der 2 also wenn ihr da
nicht sieht dass hier was absolut schief
läuft dann weiß er
einen weiteren bürgermeister in der
runde gewesen nämlich von donaueschingen
herr frey sie haben natürlich auch viele
jahre erfahrungen gesammelt in einer
stadt und haben jetzt in berlin
verstanden warum jetzt in berlin
arbeiten verstanden warum wir uns an so
vielen stellen im wege stehen darf ich
eine bemerkung zum herrn müller machen
es ist wirklich nichts schönzureden und
wir haben große probleme wir haben auch
fehler gemacht aus denen gelernt worden
ist aber eines muss man doch sehen von
versagen kann man doch nicht sprechen
wir haben in deutschland 2,5 millionen
infizierte in den usa 30 millionen wir
haben in den usa in großbritannien in
frankreich in spanien in italien doppelt
so viele corona tote im verhältnis zur
einwohnerzahl wie in deutschland
und deswegen ja es ist vieles nicht
optimal gelaufen in deutschland aber
davon versagen zu sprechen ist wirklich
völlig verkehrt im übrigen die
insolvenzen sind 15 prozent unter dem
vorjahreszeitraum
wir haben 86 milliarden euro
staatshilfen jetzt ausgeschüttet
übrigens nicht nur an firmen sondern
auch an kulturschaffende die besonders
in dieser situation leiden und die
arbeitslosigkeit delikt die pendelt bei
uns so zwischen fünf und sechs prozent
also es ist vieles auch gut gelaunt
müller und dann verabschieden werden
auch ganz lieb
wer denkt sich so was auswahl seine
frage also diese ganz menschliche frage
wer denkt sich langwierige und
eigentlich entseelten prozesse aus um
genau wo er absolut recht hat ist die
art und weise wie wir mit den über
80-jährigen umgegangen sind die 116 117
funktioniert nicht das kann man besser
organisieren und im übrigen kann man
auch nicht davon ausgehen dass über 80
jährige im internet stundenlang auf
ihren termin warten oder nicht mal eine
rückmeldung gesamt das kann man alles
besser organisieren und wir sehen im
übrigen auch landkreise und länder in
deutschland wo das besser funktioniert
hat es ist nicht überall das gleiche
und da kann man durchaus sehen dass der
föderalismus und die kommunale
selbstverwaltung ihre stärken zu
dann ist das stichwort masken gefallen
und darüber reden wir auch gleich und
wünschen jetzt aber erstmal den beiden
eltern von ralf müller alles gute
drücken den daumen sowieso überhaupt und
einen auf die deutsch-amerikanische
freundschaft denn auch die soll man ja
nicht vergessen sigmar gabriel ansehen
unser ansehen in der welt
man lacht in manchen ländern schon über
die deutschen
was wenn dazu jetzt eben auch noch ein
vertrauensverlust der menschen kommen
ich weiß nicht ob man über die deutschen
lacht weil in der tat natürlich die
andere länder auch wissen dass wir
gemessen an den todesfällen in vielen
anderen ländern an den infizierten in
deutschland immer noch trotz der
schwierigkeiten die wir jetzt im relativ
gut sind aber was in anderen ländern
gesagt wird inzwischen ist dass es
typisch deutsch und damit ist diesmal
nicht die qualität gemeint sondern die
überbürokratisierung und die mangelnde
flexibilität und nochmal ich glaube dass
das was schief läuft ganz viel mit
fehlenden handwerklichen fähigkeiten zu
übernehmen als beispiel der der
auszahlung der korona beihilfen ivana
wirtschaftsminister ich hab wirklich was
übrig für das ministerium aber dass die
das nicht können
das muss jeder wissen der mal im
wirtschaftsministerium war den fehlte
mich der unterbau dafür also wer kann
denn überprüfen ob es 75 prozent der
fixkosten sind naja ein finanzamt kann
dass das heißt es wäre von anfang an
sinnvoll gewesen es da hinzugehen
stattdessen hat man sich über die frage
gestritten wer kann sich damit politisch
profilieren was übrigens auch bürger ein
bisschen unterschätzt als ob die ihre
wahlentscheidung davon abhängig machen
welcher briefkopf obendrauf ist das
zweite ist in der tat die debatte um die
impfstoff beschaffung ich finde da gehen
wir auch unfair mit der europäischen
union um den natürlich ist es nicht so
dass da ein kommissar sitzt und der
macht das jetzt mal alleine oder eine
kommissarin sondern da sind natürlich
die mitgliedstaaten darunter ist über
monate gefeilscht worden über preise
während die amerikaner unter donald
trump mit einer bruttoregistertonnen
mentalität gekommen sind nicht wie die
zuckerbäcker in gramm sondern in tonnen
und haben zehn milliarden auf den tisch
gelegt und sich
und sagen eben statt impfstoff besorgt
mit dem risiko dass sie das falsche
machen und jetzt macht zum beispiel joe
biden etwas es waren wissen ob wir bei
uns sowas wollen
er nutzt ein gesetz das es aus dem
koreakrieg gibt und weist übrigens eine
deutsche firma an produktionskapazitäten
also das amerikanische headquarter
dieses dieses deutschen unternehmens an
die produktionskapazitäten für johnson &
johnson zur verfügung zu stellen damit
die die ampullen abfüllen das heißt dort
wird relativ pragmatisch mit der
situation umgegangen ich bin auf der
seite von georg mascolo der gesagt hat
na ja weder nicht mal den eigenen
nachbarn was liefern geht euch nicht das
stimmt so richtig viel besser sind wir
in europa nicht wir haben gerade 250.000
impfdosen auf dem weg nach australien
gestoppt das wird das werden uns auch
leute in ein paar jahren noch erzählen
aber was die amerikaner einfach besser
machen ist dann in einer solchen krise
relativ pragmatisch vorzugehen sie
werden in den apotheken geimpft sie
werden in rockstars geimpft sie haben
große feed das militär wird eingesetzt
bei uns haben sie eine riesen debatte
über die frage ob man die bundeswehr
einsetzen klar kann man die einsätzen in
der märker völlig selbstverständlich
dass in den ländlichen regionen wo die
infrastruktur fehlt natürlich jetzt das
media eingesetzt wird um die impfung zu
organisieren es gibt schon ein paar
dinge die man anders machen kann aber
noch mal das stimmig zu sagen das ist
jetzt hier sozusagen alles den bach
runter gegangen die die zahlen sprechen
dafür dass das nicht so ist und ich
hoffe dass wir wird das nicht die letzte
krise sein wird die wir in dieser art
dass wir darüber wollen wir unbedingt
reden georg mascolo sie haben zusammen
mit ihrer frau einen seltenen einblick
bekommen sie haben akribisch über zwölf
monate lang diese krise beschrieben und
geschrieben und haben private dokumente
notizen gesehen waren aber auch in
diesen krisensitzungen der
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin dabei oder konnten sie
wenigstens verfolgen
mit diesem wissen und diesem dieser
information noch mal die frage was ist
uns da abhanden gekommen diese pandemie
wirklich als eine pandemie zu begreifen
und zu führen
fehlte uns dieses führungspersonal war
der föderalismus schuld war die frau
merkel viel zu viel rücksicht auf die
länder genommen
wer hat da wien aufgehalten oder
abgehalten kann man das sagen nicht dass
es darauf die eine antwort gibt sondern
dann muss man sich ein bisschen auf die
reise dieses eines jahres einlassen das
ist ja übrigens ein ganz guter tag dafür
aus heute ist der elfte märz vor einem
jahr ist die pandemie irgendwie
ausgerufen worden
von der wiro damals mit etwas über 4000
toten und heute 2,6 millionen toten gibt
diese erste phase da funktioniert hier
sehr viel sehr gut in der politik aber
auch die bevölkerung zieht mit und dann
erleben wir so eine erste phase die
würde ich so beschreiben bis ungefähr in
den mai juni da sind wir die bewunderten
pandemie weltmeister und dann kommt
etwas von dem ich sagen würde das ist
eigentlich so ein bisschen den sommer
der sorglosigkeit gewesen dann dachte
man dass man es hinter sich hat und wenn
es noch mal zurückkommen würde dann
würde es auch nicht so schlimm werden
weil wir deutschen können das ja besser
als praktisch alle anderen ist übrigens
so ein moment gewesen wo unsere
gesprächspartner bei der
weltgesundheitsorganisation die so lange
mit so großer bewunderung auf
deutschland geschaut haben immer die
frage gestellt haben können aber was
macht ihr denn eigentlich um euch jetzt
auf die zweite welle vorzubereiten
an welchen elektronischen lösungen
arbeitet ihr was macht ihr mit eurer app
wie sorgt ihr für digitalisierung der
schulen wie bereitet ihr euch auf die
schwierigere phase dieser pandemie vor
und die wahrheit ist dass wir uns darauf
nicht gut genug vorbereitet haben und
das gilt für den bund genauso wie für
die länder
wenn man sich dann den verlauf dieser
sitzung an kopf zwischen bund und
ländern dann gehört die kanzlerin ganz
früh sie ist nicht die einzige aber sie
ganz früh zu denen die schon das
richtige gefühl dafür hat und sagt da
kommt was wieder da muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein wir erinnern uns alle
september des vergangenen jahres hat sie
über die 19.200 spricht aber es gibt es
dauert einfach der der mechanismus ist
immer dass der bund und 16 länder sich
einigen müssen
es muss ein einstimmigkeitsprinzip her
weil der bund nicht durchregieren kann
an keiner stelle und in dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gibt es
welche die wollen mehr gibt es welche
die wollen weniger dann gibt es welche
die wollen lieber noch mal zwei wochen
nachdenken und dann ist häufig der
kleinste gemeinsame nenner das was man
am ende irgendwie erreichen und keiner
fühlt sich verantwortlich in dieser
kette eu bund land kommune oder kann
wenigstens diese verantwortung in teilen
immer weiter schrieb ich glaube dass
ganz viele sich verantwortlich fühlen
und wenn man das über eine so lange zeit
verfolgt hat dann will ich auch sagen
dass ich den höchsten respekt vor
denjenigen habe die seit einem jahr in
dieser krise stehen unter diesem
ungeheuren druck diesen sorgen die sie
auszuhalten haben
aber man muss sagen dass pandemien auch
einfach nichts verzeihen sie halten
gesellschaften auf eine gnadenlose art
und weise den spiegel vor das heißt wir
sehen unsere stärken aber wir sehen auch
unsere schwäche digitalisierung konnte
dieses land ehrlich gesagt nie gut um es
mal höflich zu formulieren und das
merken wir jetzt bei der chor ohne f bei
der digitalisierung der schule aber
nochmal zu diesen da muss ja eigentlich
auch geführt werden was ist das problem
diese führung gewesen ist es so dass die
bundeskanzlerin zu viel rücksicht auf
die bundesländer nimmt ist es so dass
sie eigentlich eine starke kanzlerin
sich mit starken ministern umgeben hat
oder sind die nicht starke minister also
ich glaube wendet wenn wir uns den
herbst anschauen dann drückt die
kanzlerin ungeheuer sie benutzt worte
wie wir werden uns das nicht mehr ewig
leisten können weil sie sagt dieser
lockt da und wird auch irgendwann selbst
ein reiches land wie deutschland zu
teuer
sie sagt den satz wir werden auch für
das einstehen müssen was wir nicht
schaffen ganz deutliche mahnung
und warnung dass man da vorsichtig sein
muss aber das infektionsschutzgesetz und
unsere föderale ordnung ist in der
beziehung auch deutlich es gibt bei der
jetzigen gesetzeslage keine möglichkeit
für die kanzlerin zu sagen das machen
wir jetzt so und das machen wir so und
dem herbst kommt noch ein punkt dazu
es gibt dann unter dem
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten auch mehr und mehr
die sagen das kanzleramt und die
kanzlerin sind sehr gut darin uns zu
sagen was wir alles tun sollen
aber die liefern ihr selber auch nicht
ab wo es unsere corinna war
wo sind die versprochenen november
hilfen die auch ausgezahlt werden müssen
ihr habt uns über monate gesagt macht
euch keine gedanken über den impfstoff
das haben wir gut im griff das heißt es
gibt auch so ein gefühl der länder dass
sie sagen ist der bund eigentlich in der
höchstform in der in einer solchen
situation sein müsste so und dann sind
sie sigmar gabriel noch mal bei der
frage ich bin gleich hier bei 1 3 noch
mal bei der frage das machen wir jetzt
versuchen es mit ganz viel geld zu lösen
also all diese unzulänglichkeiten die
wir besprochen haben
mit ganz viel geld zu lösen und man
fragt sich sofort wie man das eigentlich
arme länder die improvisieren dann schon
deshalb mehr weil sie nicht auf jeden
interessensausgleich schauen und na ja
das werden wir ja noch erleben wir
werden ja da hat vorhin die landräte ja
recht gehabt
es wird ja länder geben über die
bekommen wir die mutationen zurück weil
wir zu wenig tun in der welt und weil
natürlich der impfstoff nationalismus
überall um sich greift und die reichen
länder erst mal an sich denken
ich glaube nur dass sagen wir die
probleme die wir in deutschland
geschaffen haben ganz viel damit zu tun
haben welches rollenverständnis hat man
eigentlich in so einer runde
wenn sozusagen
in der runde der kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten auf einmal es
losgeht dass die einen eher über die
frage nachdenken wie profiliere ich mich
zu hause eigentlich eher als jemand der
leben wieder ermöglicht und die andere
hat die rolle immer auf die gefahren
hinzuweisen wenn das sozusagen die
aufteilung wird und dann passiert wenn
wieder beim handwerk passieren
entwicklungen dies so überhaupt nicht
gegeben hat früher wenn die sich treffen
dann gibt es eigentlich vorher tagelang
manchmal wochenlang treffen der so
genannten chefs der staatskanzleien mit
dem chef des bundeskanzleramts bevor
einen beschlussvorschlag diese runde
erreicht ist der x-mal geredet worden
und dann sozusagen gibt es vielleicht
noch zwei offene punkte wo sich dann die
ministerpräsident und die kanzlerin
darüber streiten sollen und dann
irgendeine lösung finden die kommen mit
sonnenberg papier da rein wo gar nichts
vorbesprochen ist weil man sich auf der
strecke dahin gar nicht mehr darum
bemüht hat weil es eine andere rollen
vorstellung gehabt die eine ist die
wanderin die sozusagen übertrieben warnt
und die anderen wollen den bürgern den
weg in den ausweg zeigt das natürlich
irre
und in der tat hat der ärger glaube ich
begonnen als die länder gedacht haben
sie müssen sich aus dieser gemeinsamkeit
wir können sich verabschieden weil die
sorglosigkeit über den sommer eingekehrt
ist und das finde ich es gibt übrigens
gegenbeispiele zentrale staaten wie
frankreich machen es nicht besser alles
nicht so dass der föderalismus jetzt per
se das problem ist sondern wir erleben
in zentral staaten dass sie genauso
scheitern
aber ich glaube dass wir uns etwas
eingerissen ist ich will eingerissen ist
wo offensichtlich auch politik sich am
ende nicht mehr traut entscheidungen zu
treffen es gab mal einen der gesagt hat
der ärger der fußball bundesliga begann
als die spielerberater eingeführt worden
das gibt es inzwischen auch für die
politik hier gibt es keinen mehr
offensichtlich der sagt in meinem alltag
sachverständnis sagt mir dass ich
brauche die hausärzte das gibt es aber
ein paar berater dieser sagen sie das
nicht weil die ständige impfkommission
hat gesagt dass das jetzt nicht geht und
wenn sie sich an das halten was die
ständige impfkommission sagt kriegen sie
nie politisch ärger weil sie immer sagen
können das waren die experten
ich würde sagen da braucht es auch
gelegentlich leute die sagen ich höre
nicht so sehr nur auf die berater ich
denke auch mal über die frage nach wie
würde ich das eigentlich machen